[Music]
in excuse my French news
submitted by Pico Chico and Coco
a French waiter is suing for the right
to be rude at work in France no not even
here in Canada in Canada is it in
Montreal in Vancouver oh you know what
though I feel like French waiters are
comedians like some people think they're
rude smart asses but I think that's
their humor that's just the way they are
because they are direct honest yeah like
they're really just directly so that
comes off as rude I've never even met a
rude French waiter you might you might
think you're funny because like the [ __ ]
that they say is really witty and smart
aleck you mmm Frank sexual that's a hard
racket though waiting have you anyone
wait my thumb in New York like here you
go the Goldbach pop their sunny-side up
place so jaded I hate it that's why I
got no tips I mean I holler yeah is your
pop and yolks with your thumb bro you
might as well stick your dick in the
hashbrowns
he probably did those clientele heard
you ate mine was a little bit more
upscale he liked okay yeah it was a bar
slash bar okay was it more button was it
more of a bar no it's still a restaurant
Barcelona bar back bus or a PF Changs
sewed up because I worked at a similar
you're firing me oh yeah that's right
you can't keep a job
I remember this [ __ ] we talked about
that on your part that's why I commend
every waiter out there it's [ __ ]
tough my business you tip I'm pretty big
oh yeah
at least yeah 20% you have to you have
to yeah you have to
well I worked out volcano - yeah
downtown that's why I worked I worked
out wall Kano in near the Comedy Store
oh it's Hollywood oh I was gonna get
into it the sushi chef bro
what happens do you see the way he
talked to me you know that straight from
queer like yeah yo hey and I'm like you
can't talk to me like that bro yeah
who's America yep but Stevie can't cuz
your waiter he's the chef don't tell me
what to do giggly I'm not good with food
I'm just not good why do you keep going
back right if that's else
you killed ya fat cells which fat cells
I'm Hollywood yeah I worked in kitchen
Oh see you never wanted to repo a retail
you're just not a good customer service
kind of no no amoeba Oh coffee bean
coffee immunity leave you don't see the
tents that one I do you know what I feel
like you would make a great host what
are you talking about I think the reason
why you don't like look at this babe
what he's I don't know he needs to work
at a surf skate shop because that's do
you know what now you're talking now
your customer service I think the
problem is you be [ __ ] up orders do
you [ __ ] up well I think you should be
ski sir how do you know that did that
BAM right because waiter knows a waiter
yeah oh I Tempe improv I was a food
runner and I got fired there
you were running like the reality though
oh god it's so hard I bet you people
like you because you [ __ ] nice you're
a con or whatever but then whether when
you bring the wrong [ __ ] out that's when
they hate you or when he sticks is
Dominique you see what I don't like you
get like a big top like an eight top or
near bust you're running all kind you're
fetching them all this stuff and then
you go to the table when they leave in
it's like
nothing there and it just rage just
enters your soul if I got racist
becoming a [ __ ] waiter dude towards
what specific groups now Ike we could
pop we could [ __ ] figure out who's
gonna tip what based off their race man
that makes sense
I got [ __ ] soul races when I became a
food yeah break it down be real body
races come on how much they pay
minorities don't [ __ ] kid there you
go just say it but we do the thing okay
so like minorities don't take even if
it's fact even if it's hundreds of
dollars they'll give you a dollar or two
penalty percentages but unless they're
Americanized if they're Americanized
than they do they know what they know
how to do it right and then like it's
it's really weird dude like I feel like
sometimes like they're Doby like rich
black people that tips super good
because of the stereotype and then
they'll be like other black people that
just don't tip at all because they don't
think you deserve it and it'll be like
Mexicans that come in and some of them
tip really [ __ ] good because they're
drunk as hell they'll be groups that
don't tip at all cuz they can't do math
what about white people white people too
why be both they're the [ __ ] best
dude because this is this is their thing
don't tip a hundred percent there's no
other group that will tip a hundred
percent unless you're [ __ ] racial
stuff right now yeah dude think that's
right yeah you know you know what you're
talking about times have you had a bill
words where it's a hundred bucks right
yeah they [ __ ] tip you a hundred
bucks dude that's unheard of what do you
tie it happens when it happens dude it
happens yes only white people do that
yes
keyonna reason I got money but I don't
do that where are we bread yeah I got
money but I don't [ __ ] do that [ __ ]
what do you do what do you do what do
you do down 20 all right since I used
you know what I'm actually the opposite
because I used to wait tables I'm even
harsher on them
why you all you know I've been through
it so I know if they're being lazy or
not and even get 5 20 times like you did
yeah you're right here I've been through
it I've been through it so I know when
they're slapping yeah so if I know like
[ __ ] you're [ __ ] slacking right now
and you're just a shitty server you
don't [ __ ] deserve it
I'll give you 15% that's my way of
saying [ __ ] you cuz I can't I could I
could never not tip unless they piss me
off
yeah right and then I let a lot of [ __ ]
slide like there's a lot of cultural
things like Asian restaurants there are
a whole different levels they'll share
it what do you mean by that they don't
they don't understand the service
tipping thing and so and culturally the
restaurant service experience is
different mm-hmm it's like going into a
[ __ ] your aunties house they're not
gonna serve you the same way so I don't
get offended I'm just like that's just
the way they do things you know this is
their house what would you get offended
if they come back to you and say hey
then tip me properly I would try to
educate them one like they didn't
realize because I gave them cash they
didn't realize that the tip was in there
and they came back and they're like you
didn't tip me I'm like that's pretty
rude like it wasn't there they don't
understand a tipping the things so
that's why they come back to you and
they say you didn't tip me right because
they don't know like they don't know
that it's just I don't know any
different yeah yeah I never told you
guys the story huh like that yeah well
yeah how did you respond to that
were you pillai that story yes you're
polite back to that one mm-hm will they
pull a back yeah to them yeah it was
just like it is imagine it oh there were
and then they recounted it and they're
like oh sorry
I'm like kind of yeah but anyway this
dude here this French dude
we forgot you're a whole list of jobs
back in 1994 sorry guys so this pretty
rude go ahead be suing his former
employee for violating his human rights
he's saying I was cultural
discrimination because of the fact that
he
he got fired for being allegedly
combative and aggressive because it was
your thing French like this is the way I
am
Oh use your the French card the classic
French car oh I hate when they use it I
have no idea no stereotypically are they
cute
good circle American aggressive I
stepped up step up to your face puff out
your chest more italic smartass I'm
gonna borrow some shade right now
bye-bye
that what that is in Canada to where
they're like really nice let's like
jorssy appear I mean think about it like
American in Canada American waiting
American service right I don't know
about Canada the American service is
very accommodating where they treat you
like a king right so they're being a
smartass to you that's really like
violating the social okayness I guess so
if this french guy comes in here in acts
French then they're being really [ __ ]
up unless they're working at that talk
[ __ ] restaurant I can see that he's like
oh [ __ ] a heavyset guy comes in he goes
let me guess you're going to order the
Senate I guess like legally he should be
able to do whatever he wants he can hack
his french as you want but he can't sue
and the restaurant should be able to
fire him because it's their business
there you go no one you can't be suing
people you can be hard for you but
Canada got some different ass rules
I heard the sjw's done took over Oh at
the colleges I heard that's nuts
yeah very pretty yes like there's a law
where if you don't call people by the
right pronouns oh my darlin Deb yeah if
you prefer to be called like a lady
and I don't call you by Miss I can I can
go to jail or I could get well cuz
appropriation like the world no no it's
like I said hey hey I saw you I was like
excuse me ma'am I was a shadow your dude
it's like I can find you now acting by
accident in New York that thing in New
York right now
well I think with there's 56 or pronouns
that are now added to the list there are
too close to Canada but I heard that
they don't regulate it like it's in
place but no one no one regulates it
because I was at least the police this
time probably yeah I asked if this is
true yeah well apparently this French
dudes former boss said that he was so
harsh to a colleague that it even drove
that person to tears so it's like I mean
you're pretty rude if you're making
someone crying [ __ ] that is pretty rude
yeah but then like I don't know man
it's just a culture clash right and I
always think like if you're in [ __ ]
Canada if you're [ __ ] in America then
don't force other people to be your [ __ ]
yeah blend blend in yeah
[Music]